hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast analytical approaches to
advanced Alzheimer's disease research
presented by dr. Rene Robinson associate
professor of chemistry at Vanderbilt
University
I'm dr. Susie Valdez of lab roots and
I'll be our moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
type the questions into the drop-down
box that appear on the screen our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email if you have any trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the ask a question box and let
us know you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process for obtaining your
credits without further ado please join
me in welcoming our presenter today dr.
renee robinson i will now turn the
presentation over to her welcome dr.
Robinson Thank You Susie and thank you
I'm Tiffany and the rest of the team at
lab routes for this opportunity to be
here today I'm very excited to share the
work that we've been doing in my
research group working to advance
Alzheimer's disease research and this
has been using analytical approaches and
so as you can see here from my title
slide the way in which we do that is we
develop and apply high-throughput
proteomics techniques to study various
aspects of Alzheimer's disease so while
we also look at aging and immunity and
study health disparities and Alzheimer's
disease in my lab today I'm mostly going
to focus on the things that we've been
doing with animal models of disease in
the United States as of 2017
there were five million people that were
diagnosed with Alzheimer's disease so
this is a very high number of
individuals that are suffering from
Alzheimer's disease and it turns out to
be the sixth leading cause of death here
in the United States if you look at
demographics in terms of individuals
that will go on to develop Alzheimer's
disease over the next thirty years then
what you see is that this number of five
million individual suffers will increase
by a factor of three it's approximately
50 million sufferers by 2050 so one in
three seniors died from Alzheimer's
disease or some related dementia and
because there is no current cure for
this disease it becomes very expensive
to treat and provide caregiving support
so currently that's estimated at two
hundred and twenty billion dollars and
by 2050 that number will go up into the
trillions in terms of what we know about
Alzheimer's disease with regards to
pathology and the pathogenesis of
disease here I'm showing some examples
of that so if you look at a slice from a
brain slice from a healthy individual
compared to someone with Alzheimer's
disease you can see that there is
significant shrinkage in the brain and
atrophy so there's a lot of neuronal
loss and in terms of cellular disruption
as we know that there's mitochondrial
dysfunction and oxidative stress plays a
large part and why there is this
pathogenesis of Alzheimer's disease I
wanted to highlight something that you
may be familiar with which is the
formation of amyloid beta peptide so if
you look at this amyloid precursor
protein you can see that it's cleaved by
these beta and gamma secretase enzyme
enzymes to generate one two forty two
one two forty two monomers Emily beta
peptide and the aggregation of these
peptides result in the formation of
senile plaques that you can see that
progressively become enlarged and spread
out into various areas in the brain with
disease progression and while there are
other aspects of the disease like tau
tangles and other pathological hallmarks
I wanted to highlight this one because
this is the one that I will be referring
back to when we start to look at animal
models of the disease and so I'll talk
more about
later but you can see that these same
senile parts that would show up and the
brains of human individuals can also be
recapitulated in mouse models of disease
so while Emily beta and tangles have
been investigated widely as being causes
of Alzheimer's disease at this point we
still don't know the exact causes of the
disease and so my group we've been
interested in looking at other
peripheral sources of disease and so it
actually turns out that in the periphery
organs such as the liver also provide
sources of amyloid beta in these Emily
beta peptides that are generated there
can be traffic back to the brain you can
also see that there's the importance of
the microbiome and other signals here in
the immune system as well as in the
peripheral mewn system that can leak
across this blood-brain barrier that is
often leaking Alzheimer's disease and
initiate a cascade of signals that leads
to inflammation and other sorts of
detrimental processes so we've become
interested recently in the fact that the
immune system has been shown to be
compromised in Alzheimer's disease mouse
models and in patients and interestingly
there were a few studies that have used
things like statins or reconstituted
high-density lipoprotein and that have
been effective and reducing emily beta
in the brain although the targets have
been peripheral nature so this begs the
question well you know it's a chicken or
what is the egg were the initial causes
of Alzheimer's disease so my group we're
interested as a big picture goal to
understand the brain periphery processes
in Alzheimer's disease and the way in
which we're trying to do that is by
looking at peripheral tissues such as
liver heart kidneys lungs other tissues
plasma and to track how proteins and
those tissues change with disease
progression so looking very early at
things that may be potential initiators
and follow them through the various
stages of disease and our goal is that
we would be able to understand a lot
about various different kinds of
biological processes in this way
including things like energy metabolism
so with that sort of context in mind in
terms of the big picture goals that we
have in the lab we really realized that
we had to focus our attention to
developing technology that would be
suitable to address these big picture
problems and so I mentioned that we use
a mouse model of disease and so we are
using an amyloid precursor human double
transgenic knockin mouse model of
disease and so this model has mutations
and amyloid precursor protein and also
pre civilians so these are familial
mutants that you can find in certain
families of Alzheimer's disease
individuals and in this model we've been
able to build up a tissue repository
where we've looked at various stages of
disease so as early as three months the
animals are very similar to heterozygous
wild-type littermates
where they don't have any signs and
indications of having Alzheimer's
disease however by the time they get to
seven months they start to have early
forms of Emily beta deposits some higher
levels of oxidative stress and at 12
months 14 and later months then they
become very advanced stage Alzheimer's
disease and have several Emily beta
deposits in the brain and so are there
many models that can be used to study
Alzheimer's disease and some that
actually recapitulate more forms of
disease this was a model with which we
were beginning our study several years
ago so in our tissue repository what
we've been able to do is to take
different stage disease animals the
wild-type littermates
and the Alzheimer's disease mutants and
then we've harvested from those animals
brain liver lung heart kidney and other
tissues so we have at least six
biological replicates for every genotype
and tissue at each disease stage and
what's not reflected here is that we
also have later advanced stage animals
as well and so I wanted to highlight
here what the analytical challenge is in
terms of thinking about the fact that we
have 180 samples with which we would
like to conduct a proteomics analysis
and so the question becomes how
we best perform this experiment and so
with this in mind we began to think
about ways that we could increase the
throughput of our overall approach and
start to do multiplexing and so in this
way we we've been interested in
multiplexing to look at various tissues
they come from diseased animals but you
might be interested in multiplexing for
other sorts of issues or problems so for
example if you have a really large
clinical cohort where are you looking at
hundreds if not thousands of patients
then you might be interested in ways
that you can increase your and
throughput if you're looking at multiple
disease stages or time points or you'd
like to look across cell types or even
study what the effects are from various
drug targets then you want to have ways
to do that in a high-throughput way and
that's because as you start to look at
the overall process for doing shotgun
bottom-up proteomics techniques they can
be rather costly so here if you start
with some sort of tissue type so in this
case it could be our brain and you
extract proteins from it make peptides
you want to ensure that you get enhance
proteome coverage so you take these
peptides and subjecting them to multiple
dimensions of separations often so these
are chromatographic separations and then
you do mass spectrometry we can get
accurate masses and go on to do tandem
mass spectrometry to get better
identification of the peptides in that
mixture this overall process depending
on the number of samples that you have
can be a matter of days if not months in
order to cover that whole cohort of
samples that you would have so for us
we've been interested in ways that we
can minimize sample handling that we can
reduce the overall time that we're
spending on the instrument while
increasing the sample throughput so
being able to analyze 180 samples that
we're going after and look at ways that
we can do this such that we can minimize
the overall financial cost but also the
cost associated with time and labor in
terms of sample preparation and data
analysis so if you look at ways to do
quantitative proteomics there are a few
approaches that I wanted to highlight
that lead to the protest at we've
developed in my group so the first
approach would be looking at a label for
your proach in which you can simply take
each individual sample through the
pipeline that I just demonstrated and
you can use at the end of the day the
intensities that you get from your mass
spectra for your wild type and your
disease animal in order to look for
relative differences that change in
those conditions and this is a great
approach because it doesn't require any
additional preparation to the sample and
theoretically you could look at an
unlimited number of samples as long as
you have the instrument time to do that
however with that comes the added cost
of if you wanted to run 180 samples then
it would take you the entire sample
workflow time to process each of those
180cm posts a way to increase that
throughput
might be to use approaches which allow
you to label samples so here I'm showing
you approach sigh like stable isotope
label you know as it culturing we're
here you can incorporate heavy labeled
isotopes of amino acids and senior media
so here you can take two conditions a
light and a heavy they have the isotopic
incorporation that occurs when the cells
are harvested you can mix them together
and now you have two samples for one if
you're not working with cells e wants to
do this with tissues then you might do
this post digestion so here you would
generate your peptides from your wild
type in your diseased animals and you
would label them with some sort of tag
where your wild-type animal would have a
light version of that chemical tag in
the diseased animal would have a heavy
version of that chemical tag and again
mix them together and you can do two for
one
so these are nice and that they increase
your throughput by a factor of two or up
to possibly five with some recent
demonstrations of the methylation
labeling for our isotopic labels however
you know the limitation of this kind of
approach is that with the more heavy
isotope tag peptides that you have in
this first precursor mass spectrum you
can start to crowd at mass spectral
space and
and if you look at the point at which
you do the mixing you have to make sure
the samples are processed as similarly
as possible up until this point at which
you label and mix them together a more
recent approach over the last decade
that has been developed has been one
that has addressed the issue of crowding
in the mass spectral space by moving the
detection into the ms/ms space so these
are isobaric tagging regions where I
will give you an example of how this can
be done and so this is tandem ash tags
but the same concept applies for itraq
tags as well as stai loosing tags or
others and the idea here is you have a
chemical tag that has three major groups
one group is this group that's going to
react with your peptide so in this
example you have in hydroxy acids in
amide ester group that's going to react
with primary means of your peptides you
have a mass balancer portion and
reporter ion portion such that heavy
isotopes so carbon 13 deuterium nitrogen
15 can be incorporated into various
regions of the reporter I and a mass
balance so in this example you see a six
Plex tag that's been created six
different reagents and the heavy isotope
shift from the mass balance region over
to the reporter iron region one at a
time so that the difference in mass
between each of these tags if you were
to break apart this on here between the
reporter iron and the mass balance would
be a difference of one so what you do is
you take your six different samples you
tag them with one of these six different
reagents and then that lends themselves
to your peptides being tagged you mix
the samples together and now in your
mass spectrum you only generate one peak
and that one peak contains the signal
from all six different versions of that
peptide being tagged the different
reagents you go into ms/ms
with either collision induced
Association or high energy capture
dissociation and then you fragment this
on here and so now you have your
lines that show up one M over Z
difference and mass and this is in the
lower mass region of the mass spectrum
and the most critical things that you
can use the intensities of these
reporter ions to report on the original
concentration of the peptides in your
mixture so this becomes really
advantageous if you want to increase the
throughput and so now you can do in this
example of six flex and with current
versions of the tag and eleven flex on
the analysis becomes possible so I
wanted to highlight some of the things
that you think about is analytical
chemist in terms of trying to make these
experiments work so if we were to take
our entire sample repository for a ad
mass model system where we have a
hundred and eighty samples and we did a
label-free analysis using a short five
hour gradient in order to try to
maximize the proteome depth that we get
then you can see that we would spend
over 900 hours doing just a 1d LC ms/ms
experiment if we wanted to really go
after expanding our proteome coverage
and getting at low abundance proteins
and we did some sort of fractionation
experiment either strong cation exchange
fractionation or Hypatia bursaries
fractionation if we generated twenty
fractions and reduce each LLC reverse
phase gradients for one and a half hour
now you can see we're spending fifty
four hundred hours of instrument time
alone to run all those samples and
that's not including any quality
controls instrument maintenance links or
things like that so this is a lot of
time invested just with doing the data
acquisition on the instruments so you
can reduce that time by factor two if
you do one of the isotopic labeling
approaches that I described earlier so
you do a duplex experiment and reduce
that 900 hours to 450 hours if you have
these isobaric tagging reagents we can
now go up to six blocks of ten Plex
then we can actually reduce the time
factor of ten to nine or 900 hours now
becomes 90 hours or fifty four hundred
hours becomes 540 hours
so this becomes a bit more feasible
because now we can do things on the
order of weeks or days but what if we
could actually increase if you put to
get to a sixty Plex analysis so if we
were able to pull that off then with
less than the course of a day we'd be
able to get information about 180
samples and our repository or even with
doing very in-depth protein personation
and coverage we could still and adding
in technical replicates we can still do
this over the course of about a week in
a day so that would be this hundred
eighty hour comparison so hopefully you
can see that there's a lot of motivation
in order to develop these enhance
multiplexing techniques so what I want
to do is walk you through one of the
approaches that we've developed in my
group which is called combined precursor
isotopic labeling and isobaric tagging
or it's the pilot which I'll refer to
here after so in this example a former
alum from the group dr. Adam Evans he
came up with this approach in which we
take six pairs of wild-type and disease
animals and split them into groups of
three and so here what you see on the
left part at this slide is that we've
taken in this example liver tissue from
each one of these animals we've
harvested it extracted proteins and we
generated a triptych digest mixture and
so we can use things that are exogenous
in order to spike in for normalization
purposes like Al KC and then what we do
is we lower the pH of our buffer
condition so that we can conducted by
methylation reaction and this is a
reductive die methylation reaction in
which we added a methyl group to the
n-terminal amine of every single peptide
so there's a selective targeting and
that we use the primary amine of lysine
residues open for tagging so then what
we do is we increase the pH of a buffer
to slightly alkaline conditions and then
we use those isobaric tags so this in
this case the TMT tag and we take each
one of these tags half of the reagent
that's present in the bow and we tag it
with each one of these
six samples that's in this group here on
the left so to the other set of six
samples we do the exact same chemistry
with the exception that now our de
methylation includes heavy demolition
tagging so that we have six deuterium
deuterium and two carbon 13 atoms that
are present in the dead methyl groups
that are added to the n-terminal amine
and then we take the other half of that
TMT our agent file and now we're adding
it to those set of examples so all in
all we are able to mix 12 samples
together into a single pot and if you
look at what that would look like in the
first mass spectrum didn't you would see
pairs of Peaks that we label light or
heavy that are separated and masked by a
don's
for the isotopes on the Dunn methyl
group and then we have to isolate the
light in the heavy group independently
so that we can do ms/ms and get sequence
information to identify the peptide and
in order to compensate for coal
isolation issues that often occur with
precursors that affect the accuracy of
the report on data then we often do in
ms3 analysis so we further take a
fragment from the ms2 and then get our
reporter ion information back so we
initially did a lot of tests to look at
the figures of Merit for this reaction
and this is an example where we design
an experiment where we set all of the
concentrations of the peptides in each
sample to be exactly the same and so
here what you can see in this equal
molar sample that we're able to detect
changes across 12 different samples so
our light is on the left our heavies on
the right and then if you look at the
spread in ratios that we get if you just
take any pairwise combination across
here then you can see that underneath
our light and our heavy pair they follow
a nice Gaussian distribution and on
average we have about a 16 and 20% year
and our peptide ratios at this time so
this was in 2013 and so we also looked
at the dynamic range of this experiment
to see what was the limits in which we
can accurately detect
differences in concentrations between
any two reporting channels so you can
see that over the course of 101 up to
101 we were able to accurately detect
changes up to about 50 to 1 but once we
get to 100 to 1 then we started to see a
reduction in the signals that we got so
this gave us a sense that when this
experiment could work really well and
that - we knew the bounds by which we
would be able to pump by differences
between our wild-type and diseased
animals so we developed a data
acquisition platform on an orbitrap
Beados instrument at the time and this
is a schematic of the instrument shown
here where you have the dual pressure
linear ion trap and the Orbitrap mass
analyzer and what I wanted to point out
was that in order to maximize what we
could get from this experiment we ended
up using sample pre fractionation so we
use SCF's fractions of our peptides and
then to each one of those fractions we
did 6 reverse phase injections and the
idea there was that we wanted to have
replications
so we had three technical replicates and
with the first set of injections we
focused on isolating the top one through
seven and since ions in our ms precursor
spectra and then what we did was we had
a second a set of triplicate injections
where we focused on the top eight
through 14
so the idea was that once we got most of
the abundant pairs isolated we could go
back and get the next tier of pairs
isolated and try to increase the overall
number of peptides that we could detect
with information and also of record ion
channels so here you see some of the
results that we get from doing this
two-tier
acquisition approach so we were able to
measure over 324,000
peptide spectrum matches and when we
started to look at the number of
peptides that we could identify then
certainly the number of peptides by
adding in that seconds here a DDA
approach allowed us to increase our
total peptide identifications of 5,084
peptides what becomes really important
in this
in addition to what we identify is what
peptides we actually can quantify across
all of the 12 channels so in this case
we were able to increase the number of
peptide pairs that contain 12 Plex
information to 1,800 by having this dual
approach so I wanted to spend a little
bit of time to show you just some of the
things that we can learn from doing this
analysis and so our first example was
looking at Liberty shoe that we took
through this approach from our tissue
repository so this shows you actual data
that we were able to get from this
experiment so here you can see an
example peptide that has been a dimethyl
eated on the internal amine and TMT
tagged on a lysine residue this is a
triply charged peptide here on the top
left and both the light and the heavy
parts of this payer who are isolated for
ms3 analysis so if you look down here at
the MS 3 spectra then you can see that
on average this looks like a peptide in
which the abundance of it is a little
higher in the Alzheimer's disease tissue
compared to that from the wild-type
animal and so what we end up doing is we
take all of the spectra that we generate
in this capacity and then we can look at
the PO changes that protein from our
disease animal compared to the wall
height so that's shown here and this
plot on the right where we've plotted
the total TMT signal that was observed
for that protein across all channels as
a function of the log to change in ratio
from ad to white and so at this time
that we were doing these initial
experiments we identified about 1,700
proteins about 1100 we were able to get
quantitative information and then when
we look at those proteins that were most
statistically different with 9%
confidence between our wild-type and
disease there were 64 and those are the
ones that are represented here in red
and so I wanted to take a moment just to
highlight for us
was really exciting about this
experiment which was that one in an
individual experiment were able to look
at changes from an individual so we can
follow what happens in the individual
animal also look at the biological
variation across the each disease
genotype which in this case was two so
this is all simultaneous monitoring of
these multiple conditions and then if
you go back to looking at this plot on
the right that looks at the total TMT
signal then you can see from the most
abundant proteins at the top to the
least abundant at the bottom that we
were actually able to detect across six
to seven orders of magnitude difference
in the abundance Ed's are the abundances
of the proteins in which we were
monitoring so we thought that was really
exciting at the time in order to compare
how well we were doing with this
sweatbox approach compared to other
quantitative approaches what we did was
we went back and did a duplex experiment
with proteins isolated from these
tissues and so in the duplex experiment
this is using dye methylation with the
exception that now we're going to keep
the pH of the buffer high and this
allows the done methylation to be
incorporated at both the n-terminal
amine and the lysine residue so here
we've taken our six pairs in all of our
wall type animals where a light dye the
peptides were like that methylated and
for all of the tissues from the AV
animals those were heavy demethylated
so we have six duplex experiments we
went through and did a long
comprehensive 1d gradient with ms/ms and
ms3 acquisition and just to give you
some examples of the data here we see
across these twenty-something proteins
is that the levels of change between the
ad and the wild-type and our 12 Plex
experiment compared to that from this
duplex experiment are very similar and
you see this for things that are higher
and the ad animals shown on the top and
things that are lower in expression and
they the animals shown here on the
bottom so that gave us really good
confidence that we could believe the
quantity
results that we were getting from RC
palette experiment so what can you learn
from this really comprehensive
experiment so I'll give you one teaser
of something that we were able to pull
out of this experiment we know in the
brains of individuals with Alzheimer's
disease from PET scans that if you look
at glucose of a healthy brain compared
to a diseased brain that the amount of
glucose metabolism is significantly
lower and this Lourdes glucose
metabolism as it goes down with disease
progression the amount of cognitive
impairment goes up and neurological
function starts to go down so this has
been well-established in Alzheimer's
disease and as a clinically relevant
pathologic hallmark but for us I became
interesting was that we were studying
changes taking place on the British you
in these animals and one of the things
that our proteomics results revealed was
that the levels of proteins involved in
beta beta oxidation and ketone body
formation were higher and the ad animals
compared to those from the wild-type and
ketone bodies are these small molecules
like beta hydroxy butyrate acetoacetate
that your body uses in periods of lack
of introduce of our servation in order
to respond to lack of energy supply from
glucose and so in order to compensate
for that what we believe happens is that
the amount of ketone body formation and
the liver goes up and possibly is used
to help supplement the lack of glucose
metabolism that's taking place in the
brain and this sort of hypothesis that
came from a proteomic data agree very
well I was somewhat a bulimic studies in
the same animal model that were also
being conducted at this time ok so we
looked at how you can apply this
multiplexing and look at changes that
are taking place in one tissue at a time
from while types of disease so we've
been able to go on and think about other
ways to use this multiplexing
experiments and this is the work of a
finishing student kristina king who has
gone on to take
multiple tissues from this repository
from our 14 month-old animals and what
she's been able to do is two and a
single experiment look at changes that
happen within wild-type or within a
diseased animal across these multiple
tissues so this ends up resulting in 36
samples that she's going to look for
proteomic changes across and so if we
are able to do 12 Plex experiments then
that results in just three batches total
experiments that she runs and what was
important about doing this experiment
was over this time we were looking at
different upgraded versions of Orbitrap
technology that we had access to and so
we wanted to see how much less we could
do in terms of sample prep in order to
maintain really high proteome coverage
but also to think about ways that we
could get more quantitative information
so what you see that is that in these
experiments what we did was we looked at
experiments on the Orbitrap bellows that
were done the same way that i described
before with sample pre fractionation and
this two-tiered eda approach and compare
that to experiments where we didn't have
any fractionation and we were using
newer Orbitrap fusion the most
instruments at the time so a little bit
about the fractionated runs each one of
our se extractions was subject to two
and a half hour gradient and this was
done on a 13 centimeter column that was
packed in-house we incorporated that
two-tiered eda approach each full ms
spectrum was done with 60,000 resolution
and then we also did the cid ms/ms for
sequence identification and then we
implemented ms 3 using HC d in order to
make sure that we get the most accurate
of our reporter i and information and
this data here just gives you a snapshot
that we were able to I get this
experiment to work really well so this
is an example peptide from malate
dehydrogenase and you can see again it's
time methylated on the internal amine
TMT 6 flex tag on
I seen residue but you can see the pairs
of Peaks that show up and the precursor
spectrum and then we are not showing you
the MSM in spectra here but if you look
at the MS 3 spectra then you can see
these report ons that show up at low
intensities and what's nice here again
is that in this individual experiment
within one animal we can follow how
malate dehydrogenase changes in hard
tissue brain and liver tissue so you can
see the level of the levels of that
protein go down as you go from heart to
liver tissue and this is true and the
other biological replicate that we
looked at over here on the right
underneath the heavy peak where the
behavior is very similar so in this
experiment we had three batches that we
took through this process and across
these three batches we generated
millions of spectra both at the MS level
ms/ms
and at the MS 3 level and overall we
identified 2,600 unique proteins and a
little less a little more than half of
those proteins we were able to get
really good connotative information
across all 12 channels and I want to
highlight that this total experiment
took 15 days of instrument time but this
doesn't include things like quality
control you know and instrument
maintenance taught us how to take place
so in reality actually took a little
more than a month and I have to generate
these data and again what can you learn
from this experiment so now not only can
we study metabolism that's taking place
in the brain we can actually look at
glycolysis taking place across the
entire system and so here as an example
we have the glycolytic pathway we were
able to detect most proteins if not all
proteins in this particular pathway and
one of the things that jumps out is that
for a number of these proteins you can
see that the level of the protein is
lower in the brain and the heart and the
ad animal compared to the wild type
whereas in the liver tissue so I'm
looking here at glucose 6 phosphate
isomerase though levels of that
particular protein
higher and liver compared to the brain
in the heart so this gives us a glimpse
of what overall the metabolism is
looking like and our Alzheimer's disease
animals across multiple tissues so we've
been able to test and apply the C power
technology and different rounds and one
of the things that we I guess saw his
challenges as we were doing these
experiments initially especially on the
orbit ribulose platform was that we were
very involved in terms of the amount of
effort put and she sample preparation
with really making sure we were picking
the right number of fractions and
spending the right amount of time
separating the peptides in these
fractions with reverse phase analysis
and this is absolutely necessary on this
instrument platform in order to actually
observe high numbers of peptides in
which you have quantitative information
for all of the samples that you're
interested in other challenges of doing
this on the Laura's instrument is that
we have really long duty cycles and so
that mean that less of the samples are
actually being sampled and so we're
missing out on information there the MS
report I intend cities that we detected
in many cases were low and so we
couldn't get the quantitative
information in those cases also because
those intensities were low we were
missing data from many of the channels
which you know you can interpret that as
in some cases is that due to biology or
is that due to just us not detecting it
and then the other thing that became
really important was the number of hairs
that we actually observe so again for
this sea pilot experiment to work we
have to observe data in both the light
and the heavy pairs that we generate so
we were able to get access to
orbitrap fusion in the most instrument
and they main thing that I want to
highlight with this technology is that
you really can play around with where
you do your
ms/ms and your ms3 and where you detect
those ms/ms MSD spectra so you can
either detect them and I entrap or in
the Orbitrap lending you many ways to
increase the duty cycle of your
experiment
the other thing that we looked at with
this orbitrap fusion almost instrument
is the ability to do synchronous
precursor selection and the iron-shod
and here's a way in which we can take
multiple cid ms/ms fragments instead of
a single one and isolate those for
further ms3
fragmentation and observe them so that
was the way in which we were trying to
optimize increasing report on signals so
quickly the initial test that we did
here was to take the same set of samples
that Christina generated across multiple
tissues and now do an experiment on the
fusion loss instrument that did not
involve any sample fractionation with se
X and so you can see here we chose
gradients that were 100 in 5 minutes and
we moved to a longer in house back
column we operated this instrument using
top speed mode of three seconds instead
of top-end and then again we did the
ms/ms and iron trap and ms3 with age CD
I'm using the synchronous precursor
selection where we took four of the top
ms/ms fragments and then subjected them
to MST okay so here you can see that we
are able to get very similar data on
both platforms so this is looking at our
favorite protein malate dehydrogenase a
peptide from that one where the
chemistry is still working and
immediately what you see for this
example peptide is that the overall
report ion intensity that was observed
with the V lows using one ms/ms fragment
so single notch is nine ten to the
fourth whereas over here on the fusion
the most where we could do the
synchronous precursor selection now the
signal has increased by a factor of a
hundred so this was a dramatic
improvement in terms of ms3 signal
but also hopefully allow decides and if
I even more peptides that we could get
quantitative information so here you can
see that in each batch that we ran this
experiment we ran it where we can look
at the number of proteins that were
identified from our light that
methylated pairs versus our heavy die
methylated pairs and we have that for
three batches they're all in all when
you look at this blue histogram from the
bellows experiment we identified $21.99
proteins and this is with twenty as the
extractions whereas with the Lumos
without any proximation we identified
1531 proteins so we were pretty excited
about this and we really wanted to
figure out ways that we could start to
optimize this fusion of the most
experiment in terms of total time we
went from a 15 day experiment to an
experiment that was done in less than
half a day so 10 and a half hours so
that also is really exciting we went
back and did another way of experiment
where we also did fractionation with the
fusion animals and so now we're
comparing eight fractions that we did on
the V lows with eight fractions that we
did on the Lumos with no fractions on
almost and this is just looking at
protein groups that we identified and so
you can see that one we identify way
more proteins with the fractionated
Lumos data than we do with the other two
approaches but also that without having
the fractionation data we can generate
significant numbers of proteins so all
in all we've been able to look at 6,000
proteins
across these multiple tissues which has
been really exciting and we've been
looking at ways that we can
significantly reduce our data
acquisition time so I wanted to
highlight that in addition to thinking
about cost in terms of data acquisition
time we also have thought about cause
with regresa actual cost of the reagent
tags and so we've been excited to work
with Professor Ling Chun Li and dr.
Dustin boss at wisconsin-madison on
using the high res dye was seeing
isobaric tags that they have in there
laboratory and if you look at the
structure of these on tags they're very
similar so what I show with the tandem
as tags except here we have a different
immune reactive group and the reporter
iron group is also different using the
elusive ID and so in this version of the
tag they have 12 different 12 different
versions and these 12 different versions
incorporate different heavy isotopes
with carbon 13 deuterium nitrogen 15 or
oxygen 18 and to the reporter iron
regions and you can see that it requires
really high mass resolving power of the
MS instrument in order to detect these
talk different on Peaks because the mass
differences between the isotopes is on
the order of six or so milli Dalton so
we took these times and worked with her
lab in order to apply them to each
samples in order to do a first twenty
four flex analysis and so this gives you
an example of the work that we were able
to accomplish so if you look across this
first ms spectrum on the top we can zoom
in on this set of pairs labeled with
blue and orange and so here we see an
example peptide pair or light that
methylated peak on the left a heavy time
methylated peak on the right and now you
can look at the MS ms spectrum and see
we've identified this short peptide with
both the light in the heavy ms2 data and
then if you look at the image three
spectra then you can see this beautiful
set of Peaks that shows you that we were
able to get 24 bucks detection from this
she set of samples so we're really
excited about this experiment this was
recently published in analytical
chemistry and this gives you an idea
that we you know constantly working to
improve the numbers of proteins that
were able to quantify with this approach
because we identify more we identify
more than what we quantify but each time
we do this we've been able to quantify
more of the proteins that we see and
more importantly what you see here on
the right is that we can very accurately
get good quantitative and from
so here on the top right what you see is
a 24 flex analysis where all the
channels were set to be one to one
compared to each other so you can see
the overall variation here is less than
10% and then if you look here on the
bottom again we can see the accuracy and
approach where we've intentionally
spiked different channels to have
different ratios in them and you can see
that these are behaving very similarly
to what it was that we spiked in that
experiment okay so I'm coming to a close
here but I wanted to show you other ways
in which we can probe Alzheimer's
disease using this enhanced multiplexing
technology and the last example is one
that takes the technology and allows us
to look for oxidative modifications as I
indicated in the first slide way back my
state of stress is a very important
pathological hallmark of disease and so
briefly what we also have been
interested in lab is looking at
translation and you can see that s not
isolation of proteins is very important
for normal neuronal signaling for
differentiation of neurons for
development survival and plasticity
however when the levels of nitric oxide
are elevated and pathological conditions
then you start to have other proteins
being modified that wouldn't typically
be modified and this leads to issues
with protein folding mitochondrial
dysfunction neuronal damage and severe
ER stress and so we've been taking the
c-collar technology and modifying it so
that we can study these oxidative
modifications and really what I want to
highlight on this complex slide is that
what we can do is we can take each of
our reporter ion channels and look at
different chemistry so here what we do
is we take the same tissues that I've
talked about before these wild-type and
diseased tissues from this mouse model
and in one example we can reduce all of
the systems that are present in that
tissue with a strong reducing agent like
that dial
and what we do is we're able to use by
all Sephiroth 6b resin in order to
capture assisting containing peptides on
a resin and when we have them catch it
on the resin we can do all the same
chemistry that I just talked about with
the C pilot so we tagged with that
methylation and TMT tacks on the resin
and what you see here with the 126 and
the 127 report on channels is that these
are ways in which we actually measure
the total protein abundance as present
for cysteine containing peptides and the
other channels 128 through 131 these
samples from these channels have been
selectively reduced with the score bait
so we blocked any free files within fo
moly amide and then the ones that are
asked and translated we selectively
reduce them with the score bait and so
now those become available to be
captured by our resin and then we can do
the same sort of CNC tagging so the nice
thing about this complex experiment is
that we can get information about total
changes in protein level changes of this
specific S&L modification and we can do
that across walls and diseased animals
so just a quick test to show that that
actually works here's an example of a
peptide from peroxiredoxin that has this
cysteine at the 96 position and what you
see here if you look at the MS 3
spectrum as you see total cysteine
signals being detected but nothing
taking place in the reporter ions
between 128 to 131 and this actually
makes sense because peroxiredoxin hasn't
been reported to be as much isolated but
to have one of these acidic forms on
that takes place when you look at other
examples of peptides so this is one from
this protein here at this position 178
of the cysteine then you can start to
see levels of s and o starting to be
detected so we're really excited about
the flexibility of this approach and
ways in which we can study oxidative
modifications and you can see here from
this quick snapshot that the the numbers
of SS related proteins that we
identified
was very high compared to those from
other reports in the literature so where
there's top left quadrant 56 of the
site's we identify were consistent with
these other studies but we also
identified almost 80 new asset
untranslated sites that haven't been
reported before and these sites are from
proteins that are involved mostly in
metabolism and also in cell signaling
so I've taking you through on how our
group has successfully been using
analemma stream more specifically
enhance multiplexing techniques to study
Alzheimer's disease this has been very
useful for allowing us to look at
changes across disease stages multiple
conditions and across tissues and to do
it in a way where we're able to do it
high throughput and also maximize the
amount of cost that we're putting into
each experiment we've been able to make
this work on different kinds of Orbitrap
instrument platforms and so when we use
the bellows lower resolution platforms
it requires that we do a lot of sample
pre fractionation and two-tiered image
acquisition and I want to add that while
it seems like a large cost in terms of
the time to do this again we're doing it
with 12 samples in a single experiment
so whatever time we're spending on
sample pre fractionation and increased
data acquisition is still substantially
less than if we were doing a label-free
or a lower Plex labeling experiment by
going to the Orbitrap fusion instruments
we've been able to reduce the amount of
sample fractionation that we do and
that's been afforded by the increased
protein signal that we get from
synchronous precursor selection so we've
been very excited about being able to do
that in a different system so yeast and
in mice and lastly hope I've shown you
that this approach is very flexible and
so it can be adopted and modified so
that one can study oxidative post
translational modifications
that I would like to think all of our
team they raise a team that helps to
make all of these experiments possible
we mostly highlight a lot of the work
that Christina King has been doing in
that from former alumni in the group I
like to thank our collaborators
especially dr. Leanne frost at
wisconsin-madison for helping with the
24 Plex
that I Lou experiment and then all of
our sources of funding thank you all so
much for your time and attention and I'm
very excited and happy to answer any
questions that you may have
thank you dr. Robinson for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation screen
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and click the send
button our speaker will follow up with
your questions via email so let's take a
look at some of our viewers questions
the Robinson what is the benefit of ms3
for your reporter ion detection and how
is that different with the two Orbitrap
instruments thank you so so ms3 really
helps us to get the most accurate report
on information that we can get so often
time what happens at the MS 1 level is
that the peptide that you're interested
in isolating also can have peptides that
you're not interested in isolating they
get Co isolated with it and so that ends
up being reflected in the MS ms spectrum
where your reporter iron intensity
actually comes from two different
peptides instead of one or multiple and
so the MS 3 really helps to reduce that
interference from Co isolation by taking
a fragment from your ms ms spectrum and
then fragmenting it farther to get
hopefully a clean ms3 spectrum that that
the intensity is only reflective of the
protein or the
that you were interested in initially I
think the second part had to do with the
different instruments so with the
Orbitrap bellows instrument that
instrument only lends to you being able
to take one ms/ms fragment and then take
it for four ms3 analysis and the benefit
of the ms3 capabilities on the fusion
Lumos is that you can take multiple
ms/ms fragments and then move those four
for a mystery analysis so the big gain
is that your signal goes up dramatically
by taking multiple ms/ms fragments and
then doing the MST and that was one of
the examples that I showed you in the
talk where we saw our signal go up by a
hundred times point from the bellows to
the fusion platform thank you for that
and how do you account for differences
in signal across multiple batch
experiments yes so I didn't really spend
time going over that but these are very
you know very complex experiments and so
one of the things that we typically do
is we either spike in a peptide or
protein that is exogenous to the system
that we're looking at as a way to
normalize our data at different steps
oftentimes we'll use a pulled sample
that is comprised of all the samples
that were interested in and then we can
spike or use that as one of the channels
in our experiments and so now with being
able to use like TMT 10 Plex or 11 Plex
tags were able to incorporate more of
those full channels for data
normalization but yeah really good
question and dr. Robinson maybe one more
question
have you considered enrichment or
antibody pull-downs to increase the
concentration of s nitro sigh lated
proteins yes so so hopefully what you
can appreciate and what I showed you is
insensate ease are the SR oscillated
peptides were
low in comparison to the total system
levels and I didn't mention it but in
fact that is with using 10 times the
amount of starting material for the SN
translate type as compared to the 9 so
in this case with our repository we're
not as sample limited so we can make
that work but that wouldn't always be
possible if we're looking at other
tissue sources we did do enrichment and
the experiments that I talked about so
the enrichment that we did was to use a
thigh all sepharose resin and this resin
captures the free ion containing
peptides we hadn't quite looked at
antibodies yet but I think it could be
helpful as another layer to make sure we
can beef up the signals from those s
untranslated containing proteins thank
you and dr. Robinson did you want to
provide any closing remarks far of yours
today so I really just think you know
that it's really important when you're
trying to answer really big big problems
I guess in in your research I'm gonna
think about ways in which you can
optimize the analytical chemistry that
you're doing hopefully I gave you one
example of how we've been able to do
that and our lab effectively but we
really think this is an important
problem on to tackle so hopefully you
can appreciate some of the things that
we've done but we're really open to
hearing other suggestions or feedback
that you all may have about things that
you've been able to get working in your
lab as well so just thank you for tuning
in and thanks for your attention dr.
Robinson thank you again for the
presentation and for your important
research I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January 2019 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when the webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now and
thanks for joining us we hope to see you
again soon bye bye